what's going on everybody my name is
Jacob Sartorius and I'm here with
BuzzFeed today what an amazing day I'm
gonna be taking the Millenial test and I
hope I pass it I'm actually a little bit
nervous there's pressure on me right now
[Music]
which wasn't a real boy band from the
late 90s or early thousands I don't know
most of these vans the left boys O'Town
LFO 98 degrees I just got I guess I just
got to go for like the one that sounds
the fakest got to give it to the left
boys got it right guys all right what is
the phone from the early thousands
called the razor the lg chocolate the
sidekick the pebble I don't know any of
them I'm going with the LG o is the
sidekick I have no idea
how do you feed a Furby by pushing its
stomach by holding it upside down by
sticking your finger in its mouth or
trick question you can't feed Furbys
what's a Furby trick question you can't
feed them ah by sticking your finger in
its mouth yo what's up bro you hungry
but what's this teacher's name the
options are miss Finster miss Grunder
mrs. Detweiler miss Spinelli I'm gonna
have to go with miss debt what oh it's
miss Finster god this is just
embarrassing sorry mom
who's this guy I actually don't know
that it Chad Michael Murray Ryan Cabrera
Aaron Carter Jesse McCartney does he
sing beautiful soul
that's got to be him that's him I don't
want another pretty face who are the
stars of the simple life I have never
seen that the simple life have you guys
seen that everybody's like Ashley and
Jessica Simpson Sarah and Erin Foster
Lauren Conrad and Heidi Montag right
Paris Hilton and Nicole Richie that's a
dope lineup I'm gone with that got it
right no stress no I don't I knew who
Paris Hilton was
she tags me on Twitter all the time
Paris I love you watch would you use to
legally illegally download music in the
early thousands I actually think I know
what this is it's not MySpace it's not
Club Penguin who's gonna steal a song
from the place called line
it was limewater Wow
what Disney Channel show the proud
family even Stephens Phil of the future
and Lizzie McGuire I'm gonna go with
Lizzie McGuire cuz that's the only one I
know it was even Stevens guys is that
Charla buff that one yeah yo shut up
believe in yourself
what's group was Beyonce a part of
before she went solo Destiny's Child
pans down I know that the other option
is just to put it out there on TLC
Pussycat Dolls and the Spice Girls
it's got to be Destiny's Child do you
know what's beanie baby shares your
birthday no what does that mean what is
that question to me beanie baby no well
I failed this this reminds me of when I
was actually in school and I'd get my
test results back and I'd be like cuz
you don't want anyone to see them got
five out of ten 50% not bad it's like
missed half God half
it's whatever it's like half empty half
full ask yourself
[Music]